wait like an airstrike Sam nice poor kid
thanks to you guys I have a much better
farm now when I do push up really
appreciate toys these days are getting
so so cool Mozza little baby I was
rolling around playing laser tag with
infrared blasters that just little mate
made a little sound effects and yeah it
was so janky and then seeing the toys
that are coming about this year it's
nuts like if this is the year when like
VR and like mixed reality and like
augmented reality it's like finally
becoming ready for consumers skyrocket
toys has sent us a full box of called
the recoil system it's like it's a our
laser tag
let's take a look these are the long
guns the rows you got the pistol pistol
and they got the Rogues the campus of
bread cutter it looks way more intense
on the box it definitely looks more
intense on the box then it does in real
life here for modest you guys come here
for honest reviews you know what that
doesn't mean Tom Cruise looks taller in
movies than he does then he has in real
life so little knickknacks and doodads
we got here how many batteries of a
million dude welcome to the Sam and Nico
channel where two grown men are forced
to put toys together in a race for life
and death another bread knife do they
kick
Rico is one of the first gaming systems
to use a are enhanced smartphone enabled
weaponry it allows you to track your
teammates and your enemies in real time
using GPS and it allows you to play
multiple different game types using your
phone and the sweet sound effects as you
play like gunshots explosions all the
fun things of an FPS shooter in real
space we are now gonna go to the
world-famous Hollywood Sports Park where
we're gonna set this up have some fun
and see if this tech is the best form of
first-person shooter game
[Music]
it's like it's like if you were to merge
a video game with real laser tag you
merge them together that's what you get
you get like minimaps you get ammo drops
airstrikes all that stuff but in real
life the world really is now game here
these are called the rogue and the
Spitfire blasters and he has some cool
stuff like this Oh Frank friend
stealing my limelight yeah re G frig I'm
starting in three two one let's go
behind enemy lines with multiple threats
near vicinity game on
nice and sneaky nice and slow I think I
might have heard him inside this
container
hey where these guys go I was expecting
a little more we've been hash
Boston is closing on your position
watch your cigarette in those
three in this building
tap the enemy now to launch an air
strike I'm air striking Jake Jake and I
are it's fun written where you at mr.
preacher closing on your position watch
yourself
[Music]
that's uh a big kill here I'm going to
run into battle as a distraction I'm out
of ammo on the game good work guys kills
her she was the asset to the team you
got deaths little fact when you run out
of ammo you can't just do this when
you've run out of ammo you can run out
of your magazine and do this but once
you run out of ammo you have to find
more you have to go around like shooting
guys I'm like what's going on here
my biggest problem is just my shoulders
they hurts so much from carrying this
team do you know how to place your feet
all right everybody close your eyes
Carmichael's gonna walk around he's
gonna touch two people on the shoulder
when you get touched on the shoulder
open your eyes and identify your palate
so we're playing with no detective Oh
Michael you tell whenever I should close
their eyes again and then tell them
they're already open eyes
except going on gentleman's beautiful
day in this in this neighborhood Oh
what's up dick hey I'm just walking down
Main Street right here minding my own
business hoping that nobody gave
sneaking up on people
[Music]
did you try and shoot me I didn't shoot
I didn't shoot me I'm not a spy Nico
Nico I've got our effusing round I will
stay away from a hit no you stay away
from me no she really made Sam Ryan
stick around behind me come shooting
over here
air strikes am I'm not dead I'm not dead
I saw the sliver of help
Sam like casually tossed the grenade at
me and started hitting big things to
skyrocket toys once again for sponsoring
this video and if you guys want to check
out the recoil game there's a link in
the description below
it'll be out this holiday season but we
got to get a fresh new sneak peek at all
this fancy new game tech coming out
which I love it's really kind of crazy
seeing how much things are evolving
converge to like old-fashioned laser tag
this is a big step up check the link